these polyominoes let me refresh your
memory
polyominoes are these shades which we
can sort of form from combining
different numbers of squares together
that's important we're all is combining
numbers of squares
you'll also notice looking at the colors
right you'll also notice that they're
always connected along an edge so the
squares can't be collected on they're
connected on their corners they're
always collected like side to side or on
top of each other right we call these
guys together polyominoes just because
poly for many there's just many
different squares right do you remember
doing this task we're looking at the
mean right now I want us to think more
carefully about these because there are
different numbers of shapes here so for
example you've got there's a 1 square
polyomino 2 squares 3 squares
4 squares and so on right so there's a
particular kind I want to explore these
day it's my favorite one of the
polyominoes you had to look at them
before I just didn't tell you what they
named were their pentominoes okay so as
you can see Pinto neighs have not one
not two not three but four not there
were five squares right hence Pinto
right so this is a Pinto no now we're
gonna do a couple of different things
with pentominoes today but first we have
to start off by understanding what are
the pentominoes and I use that word very
carefully you're gonna be careful with
these shapes right have a look at these
two they do look a little bit different
don't they right I guess I would if I
were try to picture this like a common
object and say this looks kind of like a
tap with like a handle on the side and
this looks more like a duck okay so they
do look different but I'm gonna count
these as the same pentomino can anyone
tell me your show of hands what would
you do to this one to turn it into this
one hater I think I saw your hand at
first we would rotate can someone give
me a little more detail on what haters
suggest in Louise very good so if we
spin this around exactly 90 degrees
anti-clockwise you're going to get to
this one you're happy with that so if
you're spinning it around I count that
as the same pentomino now it doesn't
matter how many times you spin you'll
never get to this one but there's
something different you can do to
transform this into that anyone want to
suggest
Misaka what's the way we look yet very
good you can reflect or just flip it
over so I account if you rotate it or if
you flip it over it's it's the same one
so I'm counting all of those not as
three different pentominoes but it's the
same one okay but if you're five squares
it's not that hard is it to picture
there are other ways to combine five
squares along their edges not along
their corners to get a new shape are we
so far so good we understand what a
pentomino is now you can see there are
at least two different kinds of
pentominoes I'm not going to tell you
how many different kinds there are your
first of a few tasks today is to try and
come up with a full list a full set of
you know draw them out in your book
first you'll use this in a second to
fully draw them once you're happy with
them how many pentominoes do you think
exists that are actually different I've
given you a bit of a I'm a head start
I've started you off it to maybe call
mrs. laser iover if you think you have a
complete list and we alarm tell you if
you're on the right track or if you need
to continue working alright give you
five minutes to start have a go at least
for this first stage I think we're going
to crown a temporary winner which is
David well done David which is fine
which is fine well done the two of you
okay I'll give that a joint a we're a
joint win so these are the how many
David twelve these are the twelve okay
you've got twelve so a few people like
gain to the same okay lavon's got
fifteen good for the levonne's and
everything there's probably some
duplicates in there LaVon now have a
look would you if you're if you're close
I'm just going to make a bet that if
you're missing one or two it's not
guaranteed but there's a very high
chance the one or two you're missing are
this one down here this is a really
tricky one I call this one the stairs
the stairs are really hard to get but
some people who are you know very
interesting lateral thinkers sometimes
get the stairs first but most people get
it last the other one is a bit tricky is
that this one at the top in the middle
this one here I call this one the
giraffe because like a lights got along
next you see it
you see it's you have to use your
imagination okay the giraffe is also
quite hard to spot okay
now can I ask you all don't worry you'll
get the chance to draw these again I'm
taking them away just look up for a
second
raise your hand please if you got this
one here the second one there
pretty much everyone should get that one
yeah okay thank you hands down so I'm
really interested look carefully with me
this one here I like to call it the
speech bubble okay the speech bubble is
quite easy to think of right did you
notice that the giraffe is just one
square away from the speech bubble what
would you do to the speech bubble to
turn it into the drop or vice versa
what would you do yeah what do you see
Joe yeah perfect yeah the left top
square goes on top of the right top
square and then you get that exact shape
so it's only a single square away but it
was a lot harder for us to think of and
it's actually the same deal with this
guy
what would you do to turn the speech
bubble into the stairs where would you
move yeah what do you see yep onto the
top right to the right like over here
yeah so then you'd get the same stairs
just kind of reflected over yeah or if
you like you could move it down to the
bottom here and it will look exactly
like this do you see it okay so well
done you've found now or have been at
least showing the last couple of
pentominoes that you are didn't know
about okay the task I want to explain to
you that you're going to now do with
this and this is um your piece of paper
will help in a second on this it's
called animal vegetable mineral so you
might like to jot this down in your book
animal vegetable mineral and let me
explain what it means okay
each pentomino is either an animal or a
vegetable or a mineral and what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna explain what it
is that makes a pentomino one or the
others okay so animal vegetable mineral
that's a little subheading if you like
now I don't to spoil the answers for you
because you're going to work together to
work these out okay what I'm gonna do
instead is see these are pentominoes
right over here I've got a tetrominoes
this is not got five squares it's got
four okay so tetra like tetrahedron as a
four faced 3d figure okay or tetris
tetra
is with players played with tetrominoes
okay so let me explain to you what an
animal or vegetable or minerals are an
animal is when you can take the shape
and you can move a single square and
your shape can move along away from
where it is let me give you an example
right so this is that tetrominoes okay
so this is where it started okay now
what I can do is I can take let's see
here I can take this guy here up in the
corner and I can whoopsie-daisy if I can
catch it
I can move it down to this corner do you
agree that this is the same tetrameter
that I started with like it's just in a
different spot okay so I've moved one
it's still the same tetrominoes
now I'm gonna move this one on top this
corner I'm gonna move it down to here do
you agree it's still the same right so
every time you move a square you can't
change the kind of tetromino it is but
here's the important bit right now that
I move this last one over here
did you notice my arm I tipped rahmanir
it's like moving away it can sort of
move freely anywhere it likes it can
like escape from where it started it's
sort of like we I'm getting out of here
right it started up here and I can
freely move that's what makes an animal
does that make sense if you can move one
square at a time still say this stay the
same shape but then get away from where
you are you're an animal
okay this is what a vegetable looks like
okay so let me rearrange okay so this is
a difference I'm gonna move it over a
little bit I've gotten a spaceship do it
here alright here we go so this is a
different tipped rahmanir right I shall
do it just like the one on the screen to
make it a bit easier to follow okay I
think it's gonna be here alright have a
look
where can I move squares so long as I
stay the same well I could try and do
this right I could try and move this guy
over here to here I'm the same
tetrominoes still right where else could
I move I could move here I'm still the
same right and I could move here I'm
doing lots of moves but do you notice I
can't get anywhere I can't
scape from this one spot unlike the
animal which kind of walked off right
it's like I matter you guys see yeah
this one can move about but on that
middle square I can never move it do you
see that it's kind of like rooted to the
ground as it were so this is a vegetable
it can sort of shuffle on the spot but
it can't escape does that make sense
okay animal can move freely vegetable
can move on the spot what would you
guess a mineral is what you reckon sandy
a mineral can't move at all
so this is a mineral right bless you you
can't pick up any of the squares and
move them anywhere without changing the
tetrominoes does that make sense like
suppose I pick up this one they left one
and I'm like where else can I put this
and remain a square and the answer is
well where can I put it back where it
came from right there's no other place
you can go to keep the same texture on
it so this guy is just stuck
he's a mineral okay so here are our
twelve I said I would bring them back
right each one of these twelve and I'm
gonna ask you now previously you worked
individually I want you to work in pairs
for this one each one of these is either
an animal or a vegetable or a mineral I
want you to try and work out which one
is which okay I will tell you there's
all three types here so you may like to
try and work together what's the best
way you can you know work this out you
might like to um take this and just cut
out five squares I have a bunch of
scissors here if you do not have them
cut out five squares so that you can
move them around like I did with my
post-it notes and see if you can work
out which of these is which okay